[Música]
uno de mis alumnos alan vive en una
casita de visita a ti con su mamá cinco
hermanos su cuñada y un sobrinito cuando
termina de ayudar a la casa se arregla
un poco y sale atraviesa tres pasillos
del barrio sube una cuesta de barro muy
empinada y camina a la cuadra que le
falta para llegar a la escuela
no va a aprender con sus compañeros sino
a hacer la fila para conseguir la comida
del día de su familia
por la cuarentena el edificio está
cerrado mientras se espera la vianda en
la puerta aprovecha el wifi gratuito
para bajar las actividades que sus
profes les mandamos y para enviar las
que ya hizo hoy le prestaron el único
celular de la familia porque sabían que
iba a poder acceder a internet
le he contento los mensajes donde los
profes los alentamos a seguir estudiando
y además respondemos sus preguntas no le
resulta nada fácil estudiar a distancia
pero al menos tiene un canal donde hacer
consultas
con las aulas vacías se alejan las
oportunidades y se profundizan las
desigualdades que viven muchos chicos y
chicas hace tiempo y hoy se las arreglan
como pueden para acceder a su derecho a
aprender
sí es cierto que las familias y los
profes recibimos a las escuelas en
nuestras casas y le dimos el refugio que
necesita para seguir funcionando pero
también es cierto que se hicieron más
evidentes que nunca la necesidad de
mantener y potenciar los vínculos que
antes propiciaba el edificio escolar
es tan así que cuando los profes nos
encontramos en la escuela para armar las
bolsas de mercadería lo más importante
para nosotros es tener noticias e
intercambiar noticias de los chicos de
los que no sabemos nada últimamente
estamos tan alertas que mientras las
bolsas se entregan recorremos la fila
buscando algún pariente o cualquier otra
persona que pueda darnos alguna novedad
por la pandemia algunos chicos fueron a
vivir con otras familias cuando sus
padres o abuelos son internados o
aislados si antes costaba un montón que
muchos de ellos mantengan la regularidad
en la escuela secundaria ahora nuestra
mayor preocupación es que no abandonen
que no abandonen el año cuando la
escuela se metió en los hogares puso
todo de cabeza valen por ejemplo ya está
harto de tanta videollamada de tanta
actividad que les mandan sus profes
tanto que le pidió a su mamá que se vaya
a la escuela de mi casa
madres y padres tuvimos que alterar
todas nuestras rutinas para
comprometernos todavía más con la
educación de nuestros hijos en mi caso
fue bueno mi hijo adolescente que tiene
déficit de atención por primera vez en
su escolaridad lleva a las tareas al día
e igual que alan consultas o dudas
directamente con sus profesores aprender
a manejar herramientas para leer y
escribir mejor a él y a muchos jóvenes
el uso obligado de la tecnología nos
ayudó a generar una autonomía que no
tenían
del otro lado del dispositivo mis
compañeros docentes reaccionaron como
pudieron la mayoría de nosotros nos
encargamos de nuestras familias al mismo
tiempo que estamos trabajando en casa
con recursos escasos
atendiendo a los jóvenes en las familias
a cualquier hora planificando
permanentemente corrigiendo desde
pantallas danielle por ejemplo es un
profe excelente en el aula pero se
siente excluidos por el poco manejo que
tiene de la tecnología y la rapidez con
la que tuvo que armarse en el otro
extremo
alejandra se la pasa probando
aplicaciones intentando una y mil veces
por más que espere lleve horas y horas
y también como en cualquier empleo están
quienes prefieren desentenderse y nos
sobrecargan de trabajo a los demás
así está la escuela hoy como una máquina
prácticamente desarmada con todas sus
piezas expuestas se nos ven todas las
hilachas y un funcionamiento de
emergencia y que le pudimos dar con lo
que teníamos
es una máquina antigua antigua y noble
pero que tiene un montón de partes
atadas con alambres de reformas
educativas llegadas de escritorios
alejados de la realidad de cada escuela
escuelas a las que además de educar se
le confiaron un montón de
responsabilidades enormes y como si esto
fuera poco se la llenó de tareas
inútiles y tremendamente burocráticas
ahora tenemos una oportunidad única la
de entre todos de armarla para que
funcione mucho mejor tenemos que dar más
protagonismo a los jóvenes para que
participen y se comprometan con su
educación pero también para evitar
discusiones absurdas entre adultos que
se resolverían fácilmente con
preguntarles necesitamos mantener a las
familias dentro de estos que se hicieron
cargo de la escuela en sus casas y cuya
participación activa es importante no
perder en la escuela la que volvamos y
además convocar universidades
profesorados entidades sociales desde
merenderos hasta clubes como parte del
entramado social que colabora y se
retroalimenta de lo que pasa en la
escuela
yo no sé cómo se va a ver esta máquina
que rearmemos con las piezas que
teníamos y las nuevas herramientas que
tenemos pero estoy segura que la
presencialidad tiene que tomar un super
importante para construir mejores
vínculos y no para hacer desperdiciada
en actividades que hoy hemos entendido a
la fuerza se pueden hacer a distancia o
son obsoletas si volvemos a la misma
escuela significa que no aprendimos nada
se lo debemos a las pibas a los pibes a
los profes a las familias que están
haciendo un esfuerzo enorme por
garantizar el derecho a la educación una
educación realmente de calidad que nos
transforme a todos desde los afectos
desde lo personal y como ciudadanos
tenemos una oportunidad única que no se
va a volver a dar ni en 100 años el
desafío es estar a la altura y hacernos
cargo de pensar y hacer una mejor
escuela entre todos
[Música]